120 يوما اخرى تضاف الى الاتفاقين
للموقعين في اسطنبول في يوليو الماضي
لتصدير الحبوب والذين يهدفان الى تخفيف
نقص الغداء العالمي وسمح الاتفاق حينها
بانشاء ممرات بحريه تنطلق من ثلاثه موانئ
اوكرانيه لتصدير الحبوب هي اوديس
ويزني وتضمن الاتفاقه
يكون مسؤولا عن التنسيق والرقابه وتفتيش
السفن لاسيه ما لدى عودتها للموانئ
الاوكرانيه منذ توقيع الاتفاقيه قبل اربعه
اشهر شحن اكثر من احد عشر مليون طن من
المنتجات الزراعيه وبلغت شحنه الحبوب
وحدها ثلاثه ملايين ومئتين الف طن وكانت
كيف تطمح ان يسمح الاتفاق باضافه الموانئ
الجنوبيه في منطقه ميكو لايف وهي ثاني
اكبر محطه للحبوب في اوكرانيا وفقا
لبيانات الشحن للعام الماضي
كما شكت روسيا مرارا من ان شحنتها من
الحبوب والاسمده لا تصل الى الاسواق
العالميه بسبب العقوبات التي تقييد حصول
شركات الشحن على التمويل والتامين ودخول
الموانئ موسكو شددت على ان اتفاقيه الحبوب
تجدد تلقائيا اذا لم يكن هناك اي اعتراضات
وانه يجب حل جميع القضايا المتعلقه برفع
القيود على تصدير المواد الغذائيه
والاسمده الروسيه في غضون 120 يوما وهو
مؤكده الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
كوتيريش بقوله ان المنظمه الدوليه ملتزمه
بازاله اي عقبات في طريق تصدير الاغذيه
والاسمده من روسيا